[Music]
when i do my work i want it to have this
real visceral reaction
whether it's bringing them to tears
whether it's inspiring them
i want to show the world that beauty and
grace
are not defined by status or race
my name is aisha ash and through the use
of ballet i expose my community to more
positive images of women of color
[Music]
that's where it all began
wow so this is it
aisha grew up in the inner city of
rochester new york
where crime gun violence and poverty
were amongst the biggest threats to the
community
for us that's normal
that's just life in the hood
but what i remember the most is the
dance studio
i started dancing all together at the
age of five
a teacher mentioned to my mother that i
had some promise in ballet and that it
would be difficult for me as a woman of
color to enter the ballet world but the
adversity she faced was the very thing
that pushed her to pursue a career in
ballet she went on to become one of the
few women of color to ever grace the
stages of new york city ballet school of
american ballet i felt like my entire
career was catching up and then being a
black woman in the ballet world i felt
like i had to work twice as hard because
of that as well and there's so much
negative stereotyping and
misrepresentations of who we are
perpetuated in the media and so
i began the swan dreams project in 2011.
through the use of imagery and my career
as a ballet dancer i challenge
stereotypes that exist for women of
color particularly those from inner city
communities
i didn't see anyone
that had left
the inner city of rochester new york
and come back here
and sort of
expose all of us to look what you can
become look what i went off to do
aisha put on her tutu grabbed the
photographer and started making her way
through the very streets where she grew
up
and it was very profound the impact that
i got back especially from the people on
the street
thank you
thank you for that
there was the one image that went viral
of me with the little girls and i just
hold them to the side just started doing
some ballet class and that's when i
realized i had something this has to be
bigger than this
and it began morphing and changing and
then people began asking for appearances
and what's next let me see you it's
important that our girls see that side
of themselves because for many kids it's
hard to
be what you can't see
i didn't see a black ballerina before i
decided that's what i wanted to be
it was really important for me to be in
my environment displaying that because
this is where i'm from
it was always beyond ballet
[Music]
you